what are some of the things that the
people who are listening can do to
protect themselves
what's the 80/20 on that I will stop
shaking hands too with people no offense
wave hi Adam this bump elbow bump I
think that's just one measure I think
the other key things are you know just
don't touch your face by the way really
embarrassing at Washington State there
was a press conference about the
epidemic and as she was fumbling through
her papers she would say everyone to
wash your hands don't touch your face
she was flipping her paper and like the
thing is to middle the press conference
telling people don't touch their face it
was terrible what it what it what is it
it's not face palm is it it's like face
yeah I don't want a face palm that's the
problem
oh yeah I know anyways it's a common
internet meme now but it's it's just so
terrible but I think you know avoid
touching elevator buttons just avoid
touching doorknobs I know that is really
hard but doorknobs are not disinfected
often don't touch things in public you
have to kind of be a little germaphobe
until this thing is over you know and
public transit is the other thing like I
see like this you know the city leaders
are always saying public transit is fine
but public transit is also one of the a
confined space limited ventilation you
know what I'm talking about and it
doesn't have unlike the airplane
airplane at least it takes in new air
every three or five minutes so the air
in the cabin is being replaced every
three to five minutes so in certain ways
the airplane is pretty good unless you
get unlucky and sit someone next took
off the airplane is actually pretty good
in terms of replacing the air but that's
not true on a bus or a train you know
and so and I don't know if they use
super high small micron HEPA filters
that can filter out virus particles it's
not every air filter does so
I think the other key thing is people
ask to travel I say look at some point
you know once the pandemic becomes
really real and it's like in number
what's really real me as in like the
epidemic is literally everywhere any you
know let's just say if I was in United
States
it's an 80% of all the states you know
I'm gonna say it's probably everywhere
and staying here is no better than
getting on a plane and going there
granted you know Airport is uh is a
place exchange but I don't think I don't
think you should stop your life and
people ask me how anxious I mean my aunt
my on a scale one to ten I'm a six I'm
worried but I'm not anxious because I'm
anxious about things that is something I
can control them not doing right like
testing I'm anxious that we're not
getting enough testing but am i anxious
for the inevitable inevitable because
the CDC one a CDC vaccine immunology
head says report report to Congress this
virus is in that evitable it will be in
every single state in that sense I am
NOT anxious because it's like just brace
yourself come what may right so I have
that kind of stoic mentality obviously
not everyone does but you know protect
yourself as much as you can as for masks
surgical masks are pretty useless and
n95 masks do not filter out and
everything but n95 masks are better but
at the same time if you wear a beard
it's totally useless wearing some n95
masks by the way began eating a full
full a full steel and certain again the
surgical mask the mask what they mostly
do is it catches your spray from your
mouth when you're talking to someone hey
how's it going to have a great idea and
you're spraying you know even if you're
someone who's very careful everyone
sprays just a lot
when they talk at dinner time it's
natural but it does not actually protect
you from inhaling the virus if it's in a
droplet tiny droplet in the air does
that make sense so like it will some
sometimes people have a false sense of
security when they wear a mask it's not
it's it's actually protect others not to
protect yourself necessary
[Music]